.fr bonsoir à tous Philippe Marini le
président um de la commission des
finances et l'invité de preuve par 3
bonsoir Monsieur Marini merci d'être
avec nous et je vous interrogerai
d'abord comme président d'honneur du
groupe d'amitié Fran Sye bien sûr à
l'heure du projet de résolution qui
pourrait éviter les frappes aériennes
nous parlerons ensuite du budget pause
fiscale ou pas comme le dit le
gouvernement et vous répondrez aux
questions de Débora Claude de l'Agence
France Presse notre partenaire avec
daily Mion enfin P in Tarna nous
rejoindra pour la trème partie de
l'émission et pour parler notamment de
l'UMP dont le candidat pour 2017 sera à
coup sûr vous en êtes persuadé Nicolas
Sarkozi et vous le dites alors que vous
étiez dans son bureau il y a encore
quelques heures vous pourrez nous en
dire beaucoup plus tout à l'heure
Philippe Marini d'abord l'ouverture sur
les armes
chimiques ouverture pilotée par la
Russie conforte-t-elle votre conviction
que Bachar elAssad est un bon
politique on peut être odieux et avoir
des qualités de manœuvre hein c'est pas
du tout contradictoire la formule a
choqué oui mais il fallait lire ce qui
suivait pas c'est par trois mots dans un
dans un texte euh
maintenant je ne dirais pas que dans
cette affaire pardonnez-moi le raccourci
président Hollande est été un bon
politique il doit essayer de trouver une
solution pour
rétropédaler il a appris apparemment de
façon inattendue que le président Obama
avait besoin du vote de ses assemblées
il responsable des hésitations du
président américain reconnaissez-le
certes mais euh quand on est une
puissance militaire qui ne peut pas
intervenir seule mais qui néanmoins est
une puissance
indépendante se lier se livrer à un tel
point à des décisions étrangères à des
décisions américaines cela m'a choqué et
j'ai réagi dès le départ de cette cette
question des armes chimiques en disant
que la position de la France était
beaucoup trop suiviste à l'égard des
États-Unis je persiste et je signe et je
pense que depuis des mois et des mois
nous aurions dû nous rapprocher de la
diplomatie russe ce que nous n'avons pas
fait et n'avons pas voulu faire et là
nous aurions pu apporter notre valeur
ajoutée faire quelque chose alors
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes spectateurs
ENF la diplomatie russe elle était
totalement alignée sur la position
syrienne jusqu'à
peu plus compliqué c'est pas blanc et
noir c'était un peu plus compliqué si
l'on avait voulu on aurait pu apporter
notre valeur ajoutée de la même manière
que si l'on avait été sensible aux
signes adressés par le nouveau président
élu en Iran je pense qu'on aurait pu
trouver aussi de ce côté-là des marges
pour une originalité française la France
dit aujourd'hui notamment par la voix de
Laurent Fabius le ministre des Affaires
étrangères
que ce mouvement sur les armes chimiques
est dû aux pressions occidentales et
notamment de la
France il peut le dire il faut bien que
le ministre des Affaires étrangères dise
quelque chose ça n'est pas la réalité je
pensette évolu plus efficace depuis des
mois et des mois si ne nous étions pas
liés à ce point avec opposition syrienne
nous aurions dû rester au-dessus de la
mêlée éviter d'être engagé dans cette
guerre civile alors je vais vous reposer
la question sur Bachar etassad de par
vos relations anciennes avec lui
Philippe Marini j'ai encore une question
sur Françis Hollande il s'est dique très
choqué par l'interview très récente de
Bachar al-Assad dans dans le Figaro dans
dans laquelle c'est vrai il promettait
de de liquider ses opposants ça c'est
une formule qui a heurté le chef de
l'État est-ce qu'elle vous heurte
également mais moi je l'ai été aussi
mais par une autre partie de l'interview
euh lorsqu'il caricature l'évolution de
la diplomatie française en 2008 en
l'attribuant à l'influence des
États-Unis alors que je suis bien placé
pour savoir que c'est totalement faux
donc c'est quelqu'un qui n'hésite pas à
dire tout à fait le contraire de la
vérité alors vous avez également choqué
en affirmant que le dictateur est doté
d'un esprit moderne qu'est-ce que vous
voulez dire par la il pratique
l'informatique il a été éduqué à
l'occidental enfin il ne vit pas sous un
turban il est il est il est oui il il
massacre il massacre son peuple mais euh
il dirige un régime qui depuis l'origine
est un régime
dictatorial policier et particulièrement
antipathique et en effet il est le
patron effectif de ce régime d'accord
mais là on est passé à une autre étape
avec l'effusion de sang oui oui bien sûr
bien sûr bien sûr alors on a découvert
on a découvert les Syriens des deux
parties en sont collectivement
responsable ayez la gentillesse de lire
le très beau texte mais vraiment le très
beau texte y compris sur le plan
littéraire voire poétique du journaliste
italien qui vient d'être libéré je l'ai
lu elle est elle figure elle honore
votre ce récit figure dans le monde oui
c'est un récit qui honore votre métier
et euh vous y lirez quand il dit j'ai
rencontré l'empire du mal en quelque Ste
il parle des islamistes il parle de la
Syrie d'aujourd'hui de ce pays en guerre
civile où des bandes se répandent sur le
territoire et où il y a un amalgame
entre la politique et les intérêts
l'argent et
l'islam et s'il y a quelque chose à
sauvegarder en Syrie quel que soit le
caractère négatif voire détestable
jusqu'à un certain point du régime
bâassiste c'est l'état les Syriens ont
besoin d'être protégés par un état ils
ont besoin d'une justice ils ont besoin
d'une police ils ont besoin d'une
administration ils ont besoin d'un
système fiscal ils ont besoin d'un é
produise ce qui s'est passé en Irak par
exemple certes car en Irak des milliers
de milliards de dollars ont été dépensés
et où en est le pays on y meurt encore
tous les jours
tous les mois ce sont des milliers de
personnes le pays est divisé et le
gouvernement de Bagdad est sous
l'influence de l'Iran ce qui n'était pas
me semble-t-il exactement le but
poursuivi à l'origine est-ce que le
démentellement a proposé de l'Arsenal
chimique ilrien et je crois qu'il y a
plus de de 1000 bombes hein
euh pourrait être un piège je ne suis
pas un technicien mais euh je pense que
l'État syrien est amené à cela il faut
naturellement saisir cette opportunité
et neutraliser cet arsenal sous contrôle
international il y a des personnes
beaucoup plus compétentes que moi sur le
plan militaire qui sont capables là en
terme diplomatique par exemple ça se
joue dans les heures qui viennent vous
êtes favorable à une résolution
contraignante tout pour la Syrie tout
plutôt que la guerre tout plutôt que des
frappes qui ajouteraient de la violence
à la violence des victimes civiles aux
victimes civiles et qui se traduirait
probablement par des métastases
supplémentaires dans d'autres pays du
Proche Orient mais bien sûr ne pas faire
preuve de naïveté et mettre en œuvre un
dispositif international qui soit
applicable contrôlable transparent vous
avez moqué il y a un instant François
Hollande vous l'avez critiqué pour son
alignement sur les États-Unis aujourd'hu
ouri même François Hollande et Barack
Obama se sont longuement parlés au
téléphone ils veulent agir ensemble à
l'ONU c'est une bonne chose pour le coup
mais sans aucun doute vous savez en
début d'année j'ai soutenu et
complimenté François Hollande pour ce
que nous avons fait et d'ailleurs seul
au Mali donc je ne suis
pas systématiquement un contenteeur de
l'action internationale président
au Mali la France était toute seule au
départ oui hein et on a bien fait d'y
aller et d'y aller dans ces conditions
là est-ce que Bachar elAssad donc esprit
moderne he bon politique Philippe Marini
est totalement discrédité pour la suite
pour la venir selon
vous 100000 morts il y a euh une
échéance présidentielle paraît-il en
2014 est-ce que des élections sont
possibles dans les conditions qui
prévalent en Syrie ça me paraît un peu
un peu difficile à considérer
euh je crois qu'il faut respecter
l'indépendance de chaque État vous savez
je n'ai jamais vous n dites que la Sye
peut encore avoir un avenir avec Bachar
je je n'ai la Syrie a besoin d'un état
je n'ai personnellement jamais été en
faveur du devoir d'ingérence
pardonnez-moi c'est ma petite différence
de ce point de vue-là je ne suis ni
comme Bernard couchn ni comme Alain Jupé
alors Alain jupet justement qui dit
qu'on ne rien faire serait se rendre
complice de crime contre contre
l'humanité vous n'approuvez pas cette
phrase je pense que l'option punir le
méchant qui nous a été vendu pendant des
jours et des jours n'est pas une option
pour une intervention militaire on
intervient militairement pour défendre
des intérêts des intérêts stratégiques
en particulier et non pas pour punir
vous savez à quoi ça me faisait penser
le terme de punir au vieil empereur
François Joseph qui voulait punir la
Serbie au début du mois d'août 1914 pour
le meurtre de son héritier h alors on
peut s'interroger il aurait mieux fait
qu'il ne le fasse pas car son empire a
disparu alors on peut s'interroger
multiplier les références historiques
par exemple John Kerry le secrétaire
d'État américain a dénoncé un munique
lui il a fait référence à la lâcheté
face à Hitler comment est-ce que vous
avez reçu cette évocation de munique qui
avait d'ailleurs utilisé désir avant lui
je pense que c'est une
référence un peu un peu forcée même si
Bachar elAssad a des côtés plus
qu'antipathiques voire odieux euh la
Syrie bon est un pays de 21 millions
d'habitants ce n'est pas l'Allemagne de
1933 ou de 1939 ça ne pèse pas le même
poids Bachar alAssad vous ne pourriez
plus lui serer la main
demain si j'étais missionné pour
défendre les intérêts de la France
auprès de Lui
euh bon euh euh je le feraiis mais je
pense qu'il y a bien des gens euh odieux
sur la planète voire indéfenda et qui
ont réalisé de nombreuses injustices et
qui sont nos interlocuteurs probablement
euh tous les jours probablement tous les
jours bon celui-là il se trouve
qu'aujourd'hui et pour des raisons
évidentes il est sous les projecteurs
mais on est sous les projecteurs un jour
et puis les choses évoluent qui
aujourd'hui même quand on a 100000 morts
derrière soi qui aujourd'hui nous
reparle des violences en Égypte c'est
une question qui semble avoir disparu de
l'horizon des rédactions vous savez vous
pouvez choqué en tenant ce genre de
propos monsieur
mariné on dit souvent euh qu'avec le
diable il ne faut déjeuner qu'avec une
longue cuillère mais si l'on a à
défendre soyons bien clair si l'on a à
défendre des intérêts des intérêts
collectifs dont on est porteur si euh
l'on pense pouvoir faire le bien grâce à
un contact et en allant dans le sens
d'un apaisement dans le sens de la paix
quel que soit l'interlocuteur il faut le
faire la Syrie elle est ce qu'elle est
le jour où un règlement politique sera
en vue il ne le sera qu'avec les vrais
acteurs réellement sur le terrain on ne
peut pas fabriquer avec des
émigrés une apparence d'État on doit
parler avec ceux qui sont sur le terrain
et Bachar elAssad quel que soit les
reproches presque infinis que l'on peut
lui faire il est là il est là encore
pour il est là il est là il existe et le
devenir je n'en sais strictement rien le
devenir de la Syrie dépend pour une part
de lui c'est le réalisme qui condu
aujourd'hui en tout les cas un mot sur
Barack Obama et ses volte face comment
est-ce que vous jugez la présidence
américaine je suis allé allé au mois de
mai aux États-Unis bon sur des
problématiques économiques et
financières j'ai constaté que la
situation politique elle était bloquée
n'est-ce pas et ceci s'est traduit par
ce qu'on a appelé la falaise budgétaire
c'està-dire impossibilité d'une entente
entre l'exécutif et les chamb auouri sur
sur sur la présidence Obama la façon la
présidence Obama elle se termine mal
parce que quelqu'un qui aurait besoin
pour obtenir un vote parlementaire de
ses ennemis politiques donc des
républicains les plus opposés à ce qu'il
représentent et qui n'obtiendrai pas le
soutien de ses amis de ceux qui ont été
comme lui en faveur du retrait d'Irak et
d'Afghanistan c'est quand même terminé
assez mal allez on va parler du budget
maintenant si vous voulez bien et des
efforts du gouvernement pour réduire le
déficit le François Hollande réclame une
pause fiscale promesse fantasme ou
réalité avant d'en parler avec Débora
Claude de l'Agence France press
l'explication et l'équation budgétaire
toujours aussi délicate avec Faustine
saint-jeonias François Hollande l'a
annoncé le temps est venu de faire une
pause fiscale ce sera pour le budget
2014 une proposition précisé par le
ministre du Budget la semaine dernière
notre objectif c'est d'aller vers la
stabilisation de la pression fiscale
avec un an d'avance aussi longtemps que
nous parviendrons à faire davantage
l'économie et je souhaite que ce soit la
doctrine que ce soit le moyen que ce
soit l'instrument nous n'aurons pas à
faire d'impôt chaque économie
supplémentaire ce sont des impôts en
moins pour les Français et moi je vais
être le ministre des économies pas le
ministre des impôts au programme pour
les entreprises une baisse de l'impôt
sur les sociétés et une réforme en vue
pour simplifier la fiscalité la pose
fiscale une bonne nouvelle pour tous les
contribuables pas si sûr les ménages
profiteront d'un retour à un barême
d'imposition indexé sur l'inflation mais
avec en contrepartie la perte de
nombreux avantages pour les familles
comme la baisse du cciant familial une
hausse de la TVA de 196 à 20 % pour le
taux supérieur et une augmentation des
cotisations retraite de 0,15 % pour tous
les salariés au total l'état espère
ainsi récupérer 6 milliards d'euros la
pose fiscale oui mais pas vraiment pour
les ménages une mesure qui risque de
peser sur la consommation et donc sur
les entreprises pour cet économiste
c'est absurde de considérer que si vous
augmentez les impôts de des ménages et
notamment des classes moyennes qui sont
quand même le support de la consommation
vous ne jouez pas sur les les
entreprises c'est pas une pause qu'il
nous faut c'est une réduction des euh de
ces prélèvements et pour cause le taux
de prélèvements obligatoires pour
l'année 2013 s'élève déjà à 46,3 % du
PIB un record depuis la création des
statisques
il devrait encore augmenter en
2014 voilà Débora Claude de l'Agence
France Presse nous a rejoint bonsoir
Débora bonsoir alors vos questions à
Philippe Merini président de la
commission des finances plein de
questions bien sûr sur sur les impôts
quiattendent les Français puis sur
l'état de nos comptes publics voilà
c'est la période du budget ça va bientôt
être présenté vous êtes un des Français
qui estt le mieux informé sur les
finances publiques alors dans quel états
sont les finances publiques de la France
est-ce qu'il faut croire à cette posuse
fiscale dont nous parle le président de
la République ben il faut bien
comprendre ce dont il peut s'agir pause
fiscale si
l'oninprète posuse fiscale comme absence
d'augmentation
d'impôt c'est faux c'est faux car en
2014 il faudra au moins compenser 4
milliards d'euros de mesures provisoires
de 2013 les remplacer par autre chose il
faudra financer pour 4 milliards d'euros
le crédit d' pour compétitivité
emploi et puisque l'on a ce qui est sans
doute une bonne décision acceptter
d'indexer à nouveau le barê de l'impôt
sur le revenu c'est un manque à gagner
de 1,7 milliards d'euros vous êtes
d'accord avec cette décision sur le oui
je pense qu'il n'aurait pas fallu le
bloquer les années précédentes n'est-ce
pas et donc vous avez fait le total des
impôts supplémentairesal mon total c'est
une dizaine de milliards de recettes
qu'il faudra ser trouvé par
ailleurs sous forme
d'accroissement de la pression fiscale
c'est l'arithmétique qui le dit il s'y
ajoute les prévisions que l'on peut
faire en matière de croissance
et il faudra naturellement être vigilant
à ce sujet et vigilant sur les recettes
fiscales de l'année 2014 par
ailleurs il a été dit semble-t-il que
les entreprises seraient indemnes en
2014 des promesses leur ont été faites
par exemple pour compenser les hausses
de cotisation dans le cadre de la
réforme des retraites je ne sais pas
comment on va compenser mais je suppose
que la
contrepartie se trouvera sur les ménages
parce qu'il n'y a pas 36 contreparties
poss possible il y a la baisse de la
dépense publique il y a la fiscalité sur
les ménages est-ce qu' yoir une reprise
est-ce que la croissance va repartir
nous sommes dans une situation un peu
meilleure mais relativisons nous étions
dans une situation de stagnation moins
nous sommes dans une situation de
stagnation plus moins de 1 % de
croissance annuelle nous avons vu sortir
le chiffre de la production
manufacturière et qui n'est pas bon le
chiffre de la balance extérieure n'est
pas bon non plus la France perd des
points de compétitivité et la France ne
crée pas d'emploi et vous savez que pour
créer des emploi il faut que le taux de
croissance repasse au-dessus du seuil
des 1,5 % minimum minimurum donc ne nous
réjouissons pas trop vite il faut être
prudent il faut être prudent je voudrais
aussi dire que nos amis britanniques
viennent de
sortir des statistiques de croissance
qui sont sensiblement meilleur que prévu
or leur politique a
été d'être incitatif vis-à-vis des
entreprises de faire bénéficier les
entreprises de certaines baisses
d'impôts et par ailleurs de tailler
assez vigoureusement dans les dépenses
publiques alors les dépenses publiques
justement parce que vous ne les
mentionnez pas Philippe Marini je les ai
mentionné comme facteur d'ajustement
n'est pas et à C
le ministre du Budget Bernard casenu dit
que jamais un effort aussi important été
fait n'aurait été réalisé Débora oui en
tout cas je vois dans les chiffres et
dans la programmation des finances
publiques que l'an prochain il nous
faudrait une inflexion négative des
dépenses publiques état sécurité sociale
collectivité locale de l'ordre de 14
milliards d'euros 14 milliards d'euros
d'économie de dépenses qui pour moi ne
sont pas à ce jour de manière précise
sur un autre sujet un peu sensible et
toujours sensible les niches
fiscales on touche apparemment aux
niches
scolair différentes autres pistes sont à
l'étude vous préconisez quoi c'est c'est
c'est un débat qui a toujours secoué a
droit à tout à gauche parce qu'on ne
sait pas où toucher dans chaque niche il
y a un chien on dit toujours alors où
est-ce qu'il faut se ne pas se faire
mordre voilà je un peu la question
persiste à dire qu'il faut faire maigrir
le chien tous les chiens de toutes les
nu en d'autres et ainsi il mordra moins
à la langue mais bon mais mais enfin ou
peut-être mais je veux dire par là que
la méthode utilisée d'ailleurs elle
l'était par le précédent gouvernement
aussi et qui consiste
à viser individuellement tel ou tel
régime telle ou telle niche en les
prenant à titre séquentiel les unes
après les autres n'est pas une bonne
méthode parce que ça prend beaucoup de
temps ça érinte les milieux concernés ce
défend sur le plan de l'opinion publique
c'est négatif à mon avis la meilleure
approche c'est de tout réduire
proportionnellement et en quelques
années faire disparaître la plus grande
partie de ces niches ce qui est un enjeu
de dizaines de milliards d'euros et
permettrait d'abaisser un peu les taux
nominaux de l'impôt sur les sociétés
comme ceux de l'impô comme ce de l'impôt
sur le revenu non c'est ma vision
constante d'accord et vous savez si j'ai
subis mais là c'est une annonce du du
chef de l'État apparemment qui veut
baisser le taux de l'impôt sur les
sociétés oui mais il faudra qu'il
compense parce qu'il y a le solde et
même si les 3 % ne sont plus que pour
2015 encore faud au 3 % en 2015 monsieur
marine le déficit de 3 % vous savez il
faudra bien y arriver si l'on ne veut
pas être étrié par les marchés
financiers et Bruxelles ben nous avons
pris des engagements nous neé tenonons
pas euh nous sommes dès maintenant en
dehors des clous du pacte de stabilité
qui a été approuvé par l'Assemblée
nationale au printemps nous sommes tout
à fait à l'extérieur de cela d'ailleurs
Pierre Moscovici l'a reconnu il l'a
reconnu en nous disant que à la fin de
l'année
2013 nous serions moins bien que les 3,7
% prévu donc on
partira en début d'année 2014 14 sur une
base qui sera détériorée les efforts
seront encore plus grands à faire or
vous l'évoqueiez je
crois les marchés financiers sont plutôt
orientés à nouveau à la hausse des taux
d'intérêt ça veut dire qu'on va payer
beaucoup plus cher notre dette mais pour
l'année 2013 nous sommes encore bons
parce que par rapport aux prévisions qui
avaient été faites je pense que nous
serons à l'équilibre voir avec un bonus
encore significatif mais qu de de
l'année 2014 et qu'est-ce qui nous dit
qu'il n'y aura pas au niveau de la zone
euro ou dans le monde des causes de
fragilité financièr qui conduiront les
marchés à s'emballer à nouveau nous
sommes vulnérables tant que nous ne
respectons pas le retour au 3 % et c'est
pas pour une fantaisie européenne qu'il
faut le faire ou même simplement pour
respecter notre parole c'est parce que
tant que l'on n'a pas atteint ce seuil
la dette en capital continue à augmenter
donc vous êtes pessimiste je suis suis
réaliste et je pense que le gouvernement
a trouvé parce qu'il est bon
communicateur ce gouvernement je le
reconnais hein il a trouvé une bonne
expression avec pause fiscale mais
lorsqu'on va se rendre compte que comme
bien d'autres choses qui ont été dites
ce n'est pas la vérité vécue par nos
concitoyens cette habilité se retournera
contre lui sur la taxe à 75 % alors je
sais pas s'il a été très habile
communicateur le gouvernement mais il
doit s'y reprendre une seconde fois on
va voir la saison 2 de la durant la
campagne présidentielle de Franois
Hollande là c'est le candidat qui avait
été habile c'est là que l'idée a surgit
voilà donc on va avoir la deuxième
mouture qui va sortir bientôt il était
question ce matin qu'elle soit exonérée
pour les clubs de football c'est
peut-être anecdotique mais qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez encore une niche on
supprime une niche on en crée une autre
voilà mais c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est
extraordinaire c'est notre comportement
fiscal souvenez-vous un jour l'ancien
président la République avait dit
peut-être faudrait-il supprimer l'ISF
aussitôt j'ai vu arriver euh ceux qui
conseillent la défiscalisation
l'investissement dans les PME grâce à
l'exonération d'ISF ils sont venus ils
sont venus me dire monsieur le sénateur
lorsqu'il y aura plus d'ISF il faut
qu'on garde notre avantage il faut nous
le recréer c'est complètement fou mais
quelle différence faites-vous entre les
hausses d'impôts qui ont été infligé aux
Français sous la droite parce qu'il y en
a eu quand même quelques dizaines de
milliards Philippe est celle que l'on
doit supporter en plus aujourd'hui mais
je pense que le gouvernement actuel a
ses responsabilités comme le précédent à
mon avis il a détérioré l'équation il a
pris des mesures de quasi revanche à
l'été de 2012 il aurait très bien pu
éviter cela il a donné des signaux de
l'xisme budgétaire par exemple à l'égard
de la fonction
publ et ceci accroit les difficultés et
puis il a en quelque sorte pendant des
mois nier les réalités avant le tournant
de Louis Gallois et et et l'épisode du
CIC du crédit d'impôt est-ce que sur la
fraudte fiscale un autre sujet qui qui
est venu ces derniers mois sur le tapis
à la faveur de l'affaire Cahusac est-ce
que le gouvernement en fait assez est-ce
que ça va permettre de faire entrer de
l'argent dans les caisse de l'État
qu'est-ce que vous pensez des
dispositifs qui ont été ou qui sont
encore en Naette parlementaire puisque
tout n'est pas été encore adopté je les
ai approuvé pour une bonne part euh j'ai
même inspiré un amendement sur l'abus de
droit pour réduire les possibilités
d'optimisation fiscale internationale je
pense que l'État doit se faire respecter
bien entendu merci Débora avant
d'aborder la suite un mot encore sur la
Syrie Philippe Marini puisque la Russie
fait savoir qu'elle juge inacceptable le
projet de français de résolution à l'ONU
on a énumérer tout à l'heure les
conditions que voulais poser Paris donc
à ce projet concernant le démantellement
de l'Arsenal chimique syrien que
pensez-vous de cette position Paris
montre qu'il n'est pas au cœur du jeu
diplomatique encore une fois ce que l'on
n'a pas fait pendant des mois il est
très difficile de le récupérer en
quelques heures n'est-ce pas je je vous
dit nous n'avons pas eu dans cette
affaire euh l'attitude la politique
diplomatique nous plaçant au-dessus de
la mêlée et nous rendant apte à discuter
à négocier avec les uns et avec les
autres et aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on
nous le fait sentir mais il n'est pas
légitime que la France et les États-Unis
d'ailleurs ensemble je le disais tout à
l'heure euh impos des conditions dans
cette résolution à la suite de
l'ouverture russe il appartient à la
communauté internationale de défin
sous l'gide de l'ONU et du Conseil de
sécurité les conditions auxquelles les
stocks d'armes chimiques syrien devront
être astreints c'est une responsabilité
de la communauté internationale d'accord
perinarno DEP public Séna va donc nous
rejoindre maintenant pour aborder
plusieurs questions politiques notamment
et bien cette petite phrase de François
Fillon qui fait grand bruit je sais pas
chez vous vous allez nous le dire dans
un instant en tous les cas il a surpris
il a expliqué que le Parti socialiste
pouvait être parfois plus sectaire que
le Front national Sophie normand
PS ou FN François Fillon persiste et
signe l'ex-Premier ministre veut en
finir avec la ligne défendue par Nicolas
Sarkozi ni front républicain ni Front
national le fameux Nini qualculle ou
improvisation son invitation à voter
pour le moins sectaire des candidats en
cas de duel psfn surprend à droite
maladresse pour le président de l'UDI
Jean-Louis borlot bêti pour le député
Benoît paru à l'UMP il y a aussi ceux
que le sujet embarrasse
je et il y a ceux qui à demi-mot
soutiennent François Fillon je pense que
c'est ce que pense à mon avis 80 % des
Français cette nouvelle posture est
d'autant plus surprenante que
l'ex-Premier ministre assuré il y a
encore peu qu'il appellerait toujours à
voter contre le FN pour le parti
d'extrême droite cette inflexion est
purement stratégique bon la tactique
elle est assez claire la tactique
politicienne c'est-à-dire que son cœur
est aus mais il y a sur le terrain une
pression parce que les gens veulent et
que le Front National est des élus parce
que nous pesons de plus en plus parce
que nous sommes en pass de devenir la
première force de France dans beaucoup
de régions alors il est obligé d'adapter
un petit peu sa tactique et son discours
le PS s lui aussi saisi du sujet pour le
parti de la majorité l'ex-Premier
ministre perd la boussole républicaine
élève une digue supplémentaire il se
laisse lui aussi aller à cette montée du
Front national en abandonnant les
principes euh qu'il qualifiait
lui-même re le socle républicain et il
disait que le Front national n'en
faisait pas partie une banalisation du
FN qui ouvre la voix d'un discours
nouveau destiné à reconquérir une partie
de l'électorat de
droite voilà est avec nous
bonsoironsich sur ce thème récurrent du
Front National et des rapports avec l'
est-ce que selon vous Philippe Marini la
langue de François Fillon a fourché
dimanche dernier sa déclaration m'a
surpris ça veut dire qu'il est encore
capable de surprendre François Fillon et
qu'il est capable de prendre des
risques cela paraît peu cohérent avec
tout ce qu'il a dit jusqu'ici sur le
même sujet vous en pensez quoi vous
personnellement bah moi vous connaissez
ma ma position je l'ai livré à de
nombreuses occasions y compris ici même
donc je renvoie dos à dos et je ne
connais pas d'ailleurs l'agence de
rating permettant d'évaluer le degré de
sectarisme relatif des uns et des autres
est-ce que vous pensez comme une
majorité de votre groupe UMP ici Sénat
don votre président Jean-Claude Godin
que François Fillon doit éclaircir sa
position parce qu'elle est elle va à
l'encontre de la position officielle de
l'UMP hein qui est le Nini ni FN ni pS
je pense qu'il faut en rester à notre
position oui bien entendu c'est encore
satisfaisant le Nini ça tient toujours
la route comme position écoutez c'est
notre position et il faut l'assumer
comme telle cette question n'est pas
dépassée est-ce que les dernières
élections n'ont pas montré que
finalement les électeurs ne tenaient pas
compte des consignes de vote C lecteurs
sont libres de leurs vote vous dites que
vous n'avez pas les l'agence de notation
pour juger si le Front National est
sectaire ou Pasel candidat son programme
son programme parle pour lui dit-on y
compris dans votre camp la préférence
nationale d'autrre prise de
position écoutez je ne vois pas pourquoi
je m'étendrai davantage sur ce sujet je
pense vous avoir répondu de manière
claire et et et précise par référence à
ce que j'ai pu dire dans le passé et en
ce qui me concerne il n'y a aucune
évolution alors sur l'UMP qui est
parvenu à récolter les 11 millions
nécessaires au règlement de la datte de
Nicolas Sarkozi après la campagne
présidentielle est-ce que c'est le signe
selon vous le fait que ces 11 millions a
été récoltés que les militants UMP
attendent le retour de Nicolas Sarkozi
ben en tout cas c'est un geste d'amitié
et de sympathie vis-à-vis de lui ou
vis-à-vis de l'UMP les deux parce que
nos militants je pense que pour une
large majorité d'entre eux ils font pas
trop la différence ils sont fiers de ce
qui a été fait avec Nicolas Sarkozy il
déploreent qu'il ait été battu il
penseent qu'il a fait un très beau score
ils se sont bien battus pour ça chacun à
sa place et à mon avis ils le referont
la prochaine fois vous rencontrez vous
rencontrez souvent Nicolas Sarkozi vous
étiez encore aujourd'hui régulièement
régulièrement soyons régulièrement vous
étiez encore aujourd'hui dans son bureau
est-ce que vous avez parler justement de
ces 11 millions est-ce qu'il est surpris
heureux de ce dénouement il a été en
fait très heureux que sa parole est
portée à un tel point et c'est quelque
chose qui lui fait chaud au cœur bien
entendu est-ce qu'il en tire des
conclusions pour l'avenir
ben je pense que Nicolas Sarkozi garde
toute son intelligence sa lucidité son
énergie et et et et et qu'il est animé
par le souci de l'avenir bon
maintenantir mais de l'avenir de notre
pays il raisonne vous savez
il raisonne d'abord en terme de France
c'est-àdire il raisonne en fonction de
ce qu'il estime être bon les intérêts de
la France bon et à cet
égard il définira en temps voulu le
moment où il estimera qu'il est audible
mais pour vous son retour n'a jamais
fait aucun doute pour moi
personnellement cela ne fait pas de
doute mais il lui appartient vous dit ça
alors que vous étiez encore avec lui le
rappelit y a quelques heur mais pour moi
ça ne fait pas de doute dès dè dè dès
dès le lendemain du DIM cela ne faisait
pas de doute et et je pense qu'il faut
que des conditions soit
présente dans le débat politique en
terme de situation économique de notre
pays en terme d'opinion publique mais en
terme d'opinion publique bien que le
moment soit venu
pour qu'il soit audible pour que son
message porte ce qui laisse ce qui lui
laisse tout le temps nécessaire de la
réflexion pour construire ce qu'il dira
à ce moment-là est-ce que c'est le
moment du coup est-ce que c'est le
moment opportun pour l'UMP de lancer
l'inventaire du quinquenan Nicolas
Sarkozi il va y avoir une convention de
l'UMP au mois d'octobre oui à mon avis
ce sera une opération assez assez assez
rapide d'ailleurs vous savez qui on va
interroger à ce sujet les ministres qui
étaient au gouvernement donc on leur
demandera d'évaluer leur propre action
les mieux placés nce pas hein puisque
d'ailleurs pari parmi ceux qui ont mis
ce thème sur le tapis il y en a d'assez
nombreux bah qui étaient très heureux
d'être au gouvernement qui ont fait des
pieds des mains pour y être et pour y
rester bon donc on va leur demander
comment ils évaluent leur propre action
dont ils sont comptables tout aussi bien
que le président qu'ils ont servi
qu'est-ce que Nicolas Sarkozi vous dit
de la perspective de la primaire à l'UMP
car elle est est quand même programmé he
nous pas parlé techniquement de cette
primaire ce point n'a pas été évoqué n
pas été évoqué moi mon feeling personnel
c'est que le jour où Nicolas Sarkozy
sera revenu dans le jeu et bien la
primaire va
s'évanouir elle est programmé je vous
l'ai dit oui elle est programmé des
candidats se préparent la et Fillon par
exemple est déterminé ou compris affré
Nicolas S l de il
aoupt pas fait bon bon écoutez nous
verrons bien vous me demandez mon
sentiment je vous ai donné mon sentiment
je pense qu'elle va s'évanouir se diluer
euh je le pense c'est mon pourquoi pas
voilà c'est une référence Chiren vous
avez donné combien vous personnellement
au sarcoton écoutez j'ai j'ai donné
comme les parlementaires ont donné j'ai
pas à vous à vous à vous livrer le le
certains le disent hein j'ai pas vous
livrer le montant non moi je je je je
suis pas favorable à ce déballage
permanent non est-ce que vous estimez
que l'UMP est en endant de marche euh
pour les élections municipales de mars
prochain alors les élections municipales
euh c'est un exercice particulier il
faut adhérer au terrain donc c'est pas
le centre qui crée les conditions du
succès c'est les équipes sur le terrain
HM euh et alors du coup est-ce que l'UMP
est en ordre de marche est-ce que les
choses sont organisé sur le TER vous saz
re marche on voit qu'on fait élire un
député dans la circonscription de
villeeneuve surlotte où les conditions
sont quand même pas extraordinaires pour
notre tendance politique bah quand même
les circonstan étit très particulièrees
reconnaissez-le ah oui mais enfin bon je
veux dire que le siège de ville
sur historiquement il a été assez
rarement il a été mais pas longtemps
détenu par la droite
donc av quand même un gros parfum de
scandale he oui qui vous a profité bien
sûr ben oui mais quand on est là quand
on a des gens qui travaillent comme
c'est le cas de mon collègue maintenant
député merire de fumelle et bien on on
ramasse le profil de ce travail ingras
pendant des années et des années donc
vous êtes confiant pour les municipales
ce qui pourrait servir les élections
sénatri 201 les municipales se font dans
chaque commune c'est pas automatique
c'est une question de crédibilité il
faut unir il faut rassembler sur un
programme pour une commune donc c'est un
exercice qui est politique mais qui
n'est pas que politique c'est un
exercice de crédibilité alors en effet
les élections sénatoriales dépendent
pour une large part du nombre de
délégués qu'on peut aligner ensuite à
l'élection sénatoriale il y a un débat
Gérard Larché Jean-Pierre belle en ce
moment autour de la place du Sénat dans
nos institutions Gérard Larcher parle du
déclin du Sénat trop qui serait trop peu
considéré par l'actuel pouvoir est-ce
que à votre avis également le Sénat ne
sert plus à rien non le Sénat est
aujourd'hui sur tout le champ économique
sociale et finan c'est une chambre
d'opposition c'est une chambre qui ne
vote plus lest texte du Gouvernement il
qui est pourtant à gauche même si la
majorité est courte elle est à gauche
mais le gouvernement ne peut plus faire
voter ses texte et par
exemple lorsqu'il est question d'un
débat d'orientation budgétaire le
gouvernement s'abstient de demander un
vote puisqu'il le perdrait bon le Sénat
joue son rôle il polarise il exprime les
mécontentements de la société française
tant à droite que c'est vrai à l'extrême
gauche mais est-ce que cette absence de
majorité à gauche peut-être dû au fait
au président du Sénat Jean-Pierre belle
qui ne tiendrait pas assez à la maison
c'est ce qu' a voulu souligner
peut-être il est pas là pour tenir à la
maison président du Sénat le président
d'une assemblée il incarne cette
assemblée dans toute sa diversité il est
comme on dit un Primus interparess il
est entre ses pères entre ses égaux
c'est le rôle du président du Sénat moi
je n'ai pas à me plaindre de Jean-Pierre
belle qui est d'une grande courtoisie et
qui et
quij pourésard LCH a raison de dire que
le Sénat est
amoindri par tout ce qui est fait à
l'encontre de la ruralité et risque
d'être amoindri par le non cumul des
mandats et
par le changement de sa loi électoral ça
nous complique beaucoup les choses
justement vous parlez du cumul des
mandats l'Express a publié aujourd'hui
le PAL des cumulur de la République
alors vous arrivez en 15e position mal
sur 1573 élus
français alors d'après les calculs de
L'Express votre indice de cumule
équivaut à quat plein temps donc je
voulais vous remercier aujourd'hui
d'avoir pour venir sur plateau et
j'aimerais savoir sur quelle fonction
vous avez mordu pour venir sur Public
Sénat ce soir non mais je considère que
sur un territoire il faut qu'il y ait
une unité de responsabilité HM mais ceci
ne peut se faire qu'en équipe je délègue
beaucoup j'ai des adjoints des
vice-présidents qui travaill en union
étroite avec moi il y a un partage des
rôles je consacre beaucoup de temps à
mon territoire vous n'z pas vraiment H8
mandats ou fonction en fait ça c'est
théorique alors si vous déléguez si je
suis maire je suis président de
l'agglomération euh bon je suis
président d'un gros syndicat mixte de
déchets ménagers euh je suis président
la Maison de l'Emploi et de la Formation
du bureau intercommunal de l'emploi de
la Mission Locale de de de de toutes les
structures que j'ai cré vos titres en
route vous les connaissez tous bien par
mais là je ne suis pas arrivé au bout
parce que je pense 15e position dans le
classement de de L'Express c'est quand
même très brillant à partir d'une ville
somme toute modeste justement le projet
de loi du gouvernement permet va enfin
s'il est voté hein bien sûr par le
Parlement limitera le cumul entre un
mandat de parlementaire et une fonction
exécutive mais pas entre une entre un
mandat parlementaire une fonction non
exécutive du coup ça ne va pas régler
vraiment le problème du cumul en France
à mon avis cette loi est une très
mauvaise idée elle va appauvrir la
vocation politique elle va appauvrir la
représentation des territoires elle est
contraire aux intérêts de notre pays
c'est une loi démagogique elle va
enrichir le personnel politique au sens
où il va se démultiplier bien sûr elle
va créer des rivalité elle va créer des
zanies vous savez quand vous êtes maire
d'une ville centre et
président de l'intercommunalité vous
avez davantage de tension à gérer
pendant qu'on gère des tensions est-ce
qu'on fait du travail positif est-ce
qu'on travaille pour ses concitoyens on
traite des affaires de boutique des
questions de personne c'est pas très
intéressant franchement quel mandat
est-ce que vous allez abandonner vous
ben si j'ai bien compris bon d'abord je
vais participer à l'examen de ce texte
que au Sénat je pense nous allons
amender significativement donc
sier
amendé par une majorité du Sénat je
voterai le texte bon ensuite l'Assemblée
nationale verra si elle revient à sa
version si j'ai bien compris la date
limite c'est 2017 bon 2017 c'est pas
encore demain matin on verra d'ici là on
verra d'ici là merci Philippe Marini
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir malgré
votre emploi du temps donc débordé sur
charargé merci per merci Michel la
semaine prochaine Marine Le Pen sera
l'invité de preuv par tr bonsoir à
tous